foreign
I'm not happy I'm depressed your
daughter will spend her life
wondering what it is about her
that is making you so electric so
unhappy
[Music]
what is going on this is John with the
Dr John deloney show
so grateful that you've joined us
talking about your marriage and your
parenting and your mental health and
emotional health and your kids and
whatever else you got going on we have a
packed Studio house today that's not
really true but we do have some and we
have some parents in their kids and my
favorite thing I mean literally I love
it when my kids tell me they love me and
um the second favorite thing is when
parents and their kids come to watch the
show we always end up talking about
something that's going to make lunch
incredibly awkward and I love it makes
my heart feel good because they all know
that everyone knows that they know that
they know and my also favorite is when
uh like
uh 20 year olds teenagers
when they start looking at the floor
like
like they don't like their parents don't
know what's going on so great I love it
and so we got it today
um all right hey important
um when this show goes out when is The
Show release you guys know
September 8th okay September 8th that
will be about three weeks out from when
student loan payments are red or redo
are due
um they're back in the world we're gonna
get rid of them they're all gonna go
away they didn't go away
and I um
also co-host the Ramsay show I also
receive emails by the gajillions and
social media requests
people are
terrified they're so anxious they can't
breathe
um people have bought cars they took
jobs they moved across the country they
bought homes they made significant
changes to their life with this idea
that this burden would be gone and it's
not
um and so
um on September 12th at 7 pm we're gonna
learn like
um my friends here my colleagues here
Jade warshaw and some and some others
are going to
um do a live stream 100 free and what do
you do now
like how do you get rid of these student
loans forever there is no Cavalry coming
there's no White Horse coming to rescue
you you're gonna have to pay him back
um I've done it it's awful I paid back
six figures Jade paid back almost half a
million dollars her and her husband
seven years they just ground it out
um so her and a couple other my
colleagues are going to be walking
through what do you do how do you get
rid of these things forever I'm sick of
waiting on the government I'm sick of
waiting for all these things register
today at ramseysolutions.com student
loans and again if you're anxious about
what to do next check that out okay
let's go out to um Dallas Texas and talk
to two money let's talk to Trent what's
up Trent
hey how are you partying man what about
you
man I'm doing I'm doing all right thank
you so much for having me on the show
I'm a huge fan it's an honor to get to
talk to you right now I appreciate that
man what's up
hey uh so I've been struggling for a
while like prob probably like the last
three years like a lot of people
um and I'm just wondering how do you
how do you like reconcile mistakes that
you've made in your past and like
still find a way to uh excuse me
um to feel fulfilled in life um I'm kind
of in a place right now where I just
don't know
if I'm ever going to be able to feel
just peace what'd you do that's so bad
that this many years later you can't
breathe
see
the issue is uh
I have a lot of Shame about feeling this
way so
if you don't mind I'll take you back to
about 20 20 it was it was 2020. um and
I'm sitting on the couch in my apartment
with my wife
and I'm not happy I'm depressed because
of covid and the quarantine and it's all
got us all shut down and I'm sitting
there thinking about I don't know if
this is the life that I want I have no
idea what I'm gonna do I don't know if I
want to stay married those kind of
things
um how long have you been married
uh four years now so you're about
married about a year in
yeah okay so people tell me no no no no
no you were about a year in when you
started having this like what am I doing
yes yeah so before we keep going I just
want to socially Norm that's the nerd
word I want to
let you know I had those exact same
thoughts
in fact I sat down with my wife and said
I don't think we've done the right thing
what do we do next how do we untangle
this because this is not going to work
and that was 21 years ago okay so I want
you to know you're not crazy that's a
super common sitting there next to
somebody going what have I done
okay right okay so bring it keep going
yeah and as I'm laying on the couch
having those thoughts and I'm not really
feeling it but like inside I'm just full
of turmoil you're showing it and uh it's
all over the place but go ahead no no no
no I'm so
go to the bathroom and she goes hey babe
I'm pregnant
um fail
yeah
not planned uh definitely it wasn't our
idea to get pregnant in the middle of
that whole mess that was going on and um
you know I feel so bad because she had
always wanted a kid and uh
you know you see those videos of Lies
when they tell their husbands that
they're pregnant and the husband just
has this overflowing reaction of joy and
it's this heartfelt thing and I lay
there on the couch and had a panic
attack
okay
foreign
of What's led me to where I'm at today
um well and I'm hearing it and if you
were here if you were watching me live
you would see like
that doesn't surprise me and there it
would have been neat to have an
Instagram moment and it would have been
cool to like be flooded with emotions
but we were in the middle of an
international
Health crisis that might kill us all and
so your first instinct your body went oh
no I can barely Keep Us Alive much less
a child that's not crazy in fact I would
think it was more normal than going all
right right I mean right right
no for sure and then uh
and I've I've battled with depression
and anxiety my since I was a teenager
like it's something I've dealt with it
kind of ends and flows up and down uh it
just I just manage it and uh
so
over the last few years you know when
she said I was pregnant I put all my
feelings aside and was like well okay
regardless of how I feel for the
marriage like
I want to give my daughter a you know a
complete family a household I want to be
a good dad and I want to be present
so that's what I've been trying to do
so we moved out of our apartment got
into a house and like now fast forward a
long time I'm in a lot of debt uh
I work a hard job
I just this is just I feel like if 18
year old me was looking at 27 year old
me he'd be so disappointed
and your 18 year old you was an idiot
um I'm sure he is right yeah he was he
was 18 year old me bathed on a weekly
schedule followed Pantera around and was
like you know what I mean like if 18
year old me was insane I hope 18 year
old me doesn't like me that tells me
I've grown up some
sure like that's a that's a bad
comparison
that's fair
um and I'll admit I was a dumb 18 year
old like everybody else
um yes
my my dilemma right now is that I feel
like I have this life that so many
people really would want
and I'm so selfish that I can't find a
way to just be content and happy in it
that's that's just what I'm dealing with
okay
um
you've talked about wanting to take care
of your wife you talked about wanting to
take care of your kid
what happened to Trent that Trent thinks
Trent sucks
why do you think so little of Trent that
Trent is worth having a peaceful life
which by the way is the greatest gift
you can give your kid is not a
five-bedroom house but it may be a
two-bedroom apartment where there's
peace because that's what y'all can
afford right now
or right maybe some significant serious
marriage counseling and your wife's got
a role to play in this too
um
where y'all create a house that's full
of warmth and laughter as much as
possible in this crazy world as opposed
to I'm gonna make sure there's this
suburban and this thing and this style
of backpack and this kind of lunch box
and so I am going to live as though I'm
on on fire so that we have this crap
does that see what I'm saying like what
what happened to Trent because Trent
deserves so much more than the life he's
allowing himself to live
I guess I guess
I don't think you ever had it man
you could be right there as well
because here's what it sounds like
you're trying to do it sounds like
you're trying to get to a particular
Finish Line and that Finish Line might
be number of cars size of house
um a number of kids a number of times
you have sex in a week
um net worth whatever metric you're
putting up for yourself as normal uh
whatever that's supposed to mean and
you're trying to achieve peace and the
you've heard me say this a million times
on the show the crappiest part about
making a hundred thousand dollars for
the first time is that you go with you
you're the one that cashes that paycheck
and if you don't like yourself with 40
Grand you are not gonna like yourself
with 100 Grand and you're gonna hate
yourself with a million
yeah
no it makes sense and here's my future
can I can I be ugly for a second like
pretty direct please do no please do
um your daughter will spend her life
wondering what it is about her
that is making you so Electric
so unhappy
and my guess is you were put in a
position to make Mom and Dad happy
is that fair
yeah don't make mom mad if you say this
dad's gonna get angry is that you
growing up
yep okay
and so what you did was your identity
becomes rooted in what other people
expect of me my job on Earth is to make
sure other people fill in the blank
and that keeps you alive when you're a
kid and when you get older you become
untethered
and you start chasing I need something
to feel good
that makes sense so the question I'll
ask you man like from the inside out
um and don't be scared of the answer
you're not gonna Shock Me
what do you want man put it put aside
the house put aside the the cars put
aside the what what do you want
[Music]
that's honestly John that's the question
that I've been I've been trying to ask
myself and this is why I feel
so stuck because I feel like even if I
and I'm not I don't want to do this I'm
not going to do this but like even if I
were to
leave my family
go off and do my own thing
I'd be so miserable I'd be so miserable
you'd go know that that's right so right
let me ask you um I think an easier
question but a a different one not what
do you want that's people will go to
counseling for years to answer that
question that's a hard question to
answer
what do you want your house to feel like
when you get home every day
I feel
like like a home I just want to get home
what is it what does that mean because
here's I'll tell you my house I'll give
you some words
when I walk in the door you know what I
just want to feel I want to feel like my
wife likes me
I just want to feel like she's happy I'm
there
and I I my kids are kids right so I'm
not going to Outsource my feelings to
them but I want there to be a sense of
my daughter running at me with a sword
and a pillow trying to stab me with her
imaginary thing and my son sitting there
working on his novel like a good little
nerd like I like I want it to feel like
that you see what I'm saying there's
nothing great yeah but when I did that
math
I had to get rid of a bunch of stuff
that I had taken I had taken loans out
on
because my wife didn't like me when I
was stressed out all the time and I was
stressed out when I owed a bunch of
people money all the time
see what I'm saying so yeah when you
walk in your house what do you want to
feel like
I guess I want that I want I want to
feel light I want that weight of of life
to just I want the world to be outside
and when I walk in I want that to not be
in the world anymore I want the weight
of everything to just be lifted off um
you might be talking about your kids and
I don't want to make it sound like I
don't like my family when my daughter I
don't hear that at all
okay I hear that I hear that you don't
like Trent
I hear that you love your daughter
beyond the end of time and I actually
think you love your wife beyond the end
of time you don't like that you they
have anchored themselves to you a guy
that you don't like
and you thought all of this was supposed
to feel differently
yeah that's probably pretty fair
so so here here's the here's the path
you got forward okay path number one is
you keep running
and you keep achieving and you keep
hustling you keep grinding out at work
and you're gonna have a customer come in
one day and she's beautiful and
hilarious
and
she's gonna make you laugh and you're
gonna think about her and she's like
that happens to all of us right there's
beautiful hilarious people everywhere
and then she's going to come back the
next month
and then she's gonna say all right I'll
be back in two weeks for my next order
and you're gonna be waiting for her the
next time
and then you're gonna get her number and
then it all goes sideways that way okay
that's that's number one
okay that hasn't already happened some
version of that it's coming
my guess is you it's probably shown up
before the second one
is you get a babysitter for your kid and
you take your wife out and you say
the life I'm creating for us is making
me insane
and I love you more than life itself and
I've tried to show you I love you with
all this stuff
and I need to do something different
okay
I also think you need to call a minute
stay on the line I'm going to send you
um three months of free counseling with
my buddies of better help I think you
need to call and you need to ask them
like when you talk to the counselor what
are you working on today I don't like me
and my daughter deserves a husband I
mean a dad who loves himself enough to
take care of himself enough to be an
anchor my wife deserves a husband who's
not trying to use her to make himself
feel better
and I want you all to work work through
that is that fair
totally fair
um totally fair in this uh building a
non-exist life book I just put out
um there's a chapter in there called
choose freedom and it's not like uh
Eagles and like uh American flag
underwear that's not what I mean
um yeah
it's taking a true inventory of who is
telling you
what you need to be doing every second
of every day where are those shoulds
coming from or have Deuce coming from
some of them come from a bank saying you
have to go to work tomorrow at this
crappy job because you owe me or a car
dealership or a clothing credit card or
whatever
sometimes it's in-laws telling you when
you're gonna do Christmas and how you're
gonna do whatever and my granddaughter
is not going to go to that school so you
like
and you go on and on and on down the
list and so I think an important
exercise for you I'm going to send you a
free copy of the book too but I I want
you to go through that exercise
where is this voice coming from who's
the person telling me all these things
that I should be doing this and I should
feel like this and I
because what you're going to find is
it's not you
it's your mom it's your dad it's your
coach it's some well-meaning but kind of
moronic Pastor from your childhood it's
it's whoever man it's people you work
with
and at some point you have to take
ownership back of those voices does that
make sense
totally makes sense and I'll probably do
that exercise today
okay that'd be I I would love that and
um
dude I'd love to have you back on with
your wife sometime you think she'd be
willing to do that
um yeah
yeah I think she would be I didn't tell
her I was calling you today
um I was kind of
involved and uh talked to her about this
for sure I think she would love to come
on all right so just to peek behind the
curtain okay
this morning um I have a close friend
who's in a really um tough situation
with one of his kids those kids is I'm
sick
and
um
one of the most extraordinary beautiful
little kids I've ever had the presence I
mean the the honor to meet
and he called me and asked me a question
and I thought I knew the answer but just
to make sure
um I called one of my friends um and
I've had her on the show Lynn Jennings
Dr Jennings back there in Texas who's an
expert with working with kids and she
said in her own wonderful way with all
due respect John you're way off on this
one
and here's this and here's this and
here's why and she gave me the
developmental research because that's
how nerds talk to each other but here's
the thing I was wrong
and here's what I got the opportunity to
be a little less wrong
right like there's no shame or
embarrassment I didn't know okay so
similarly
I want you to free yourself man from the
shame and embarrassment of all right I'm
four years in I have a kid that was a
surprise and I've got a wife that we're
still figuring out do we like how we
even like each other
okay those are skills I don't have
you've never been a married for four
years with a kid this is all new cut
yourself some slack man no shame here
what you're doing is you're finding out
answers and that's gonna help you be a
better husband better dad and quite
honestly it's gonna help you make peace
with Trent because I think Trent is a
pretty good guy
I think if you ask the people in your
life or if I did what do you think about
Trent they probably tell me good stuff
I think there's one person who doesn't
like Trent that's you
and you can make all the money in the
world and you can get your kid all the
nice things make sure your wife is
clothed in rubies and whatever
[Music]
but if you don't like you mean it's all
for not
it's all for not
and on the light man we'll hook you up
we'll be right back
this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
hey this is deloni I hope you all are
doing well listen sometimes it's hard to
get our brains to turn off and I know
what I'm talking about I am the king of
racing thoughts they've kept me up at
night they've got me up early and kept
me from connecting with people I love if
you find your thoughts start to race
right before bed or during other super
inconvenient times a great way to make
those racing thoughts slow down or stop
is to talk them through and therapy gave
me a place to do that so I could get off
the negative thought treadmill learn
positive coping skills set healthy
boundaries and find some mental and
emotional peace and it can help you too
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try better help is
convenient because it's entirely online
so it's flexible and can fit into your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can even
switch therapists at any time for no
extra charge so take a break from racing
Thoughts with better help visit
betterhelp.com baloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go out to Joe
in Chicago hey that kind of Rhymes all
right what's up Joe
Sean thank you so much for taking my
call of course what's happening
um I have a quandary
um quandria oh that's a word that we've
never heard on the show I think this is
the first quandary excellent there you
go grab a nickel for that too
um
um my quandary is my issue is I grew up
very Catholic very obedient without
contest that is fantastic very Catholic
okay yes and and you know like so you
are great at following rules and you do
not ask questions
no I exactly exactly that and it's
because
an issue as an adult correct um and it
is it has turned me into a people
pleaser it has turned me into a little
sex sorry um success pursuing machine
that is always tired and it is ruining
my relationship with people is this is
this from church or is this from your
parents
I think it's a little of both to be very
honest okay
um
um my mom who is a wonderful lady she
raised me as a single woman
um my dad chose to leave
um I'm smiling here when you watch the
Youtube you can see me laughing just
then anytime somebody says my mom she
was amazing and then there's always a
butt or like or my dad was so great but
I mean they're they're your first love
they're your first nurturers they're
your first interaction with everything
and they can also be your first abusers
and they can be your first person who
used you to make themselves feel better
about themselves it's all true at the
same time right yes it is okay and um my
father was an abusive individual and my
mother didn't want us growing around
um that in that kind of an environment
good for her so she left she immigrated
to the United States by herself with two
toddlers
so she's a tough strong woman right
you got that right okay you don't mess
with her and
um you know she and you know being an
adult I recognize the hardships of that
I recognize not knowing anybody and
taking your children and truly just
relying on your faith and your your
tenacity to work and your mind so as I
grew up and I got older I began to
question things this anybody does
um and I became skeptical about a lot of
things and it wasn't until very recently
I started realizing am I being obedient
or am I honoring my mother
um which is a big a big exhale but also
a big suspended breath in my chest
because it is one of the things that you
know I try to do I try to be a good
Christian person
but also try to live my life so
obedience and honor are not are not one
in the same
obedience and honor are mutually
exclusive here's what I mean
um when you're 10
and your mom says take out the trash
because you're a member of our household
and you play a role here too
honoring your mom is taking out the
trash
right um
if you're 13 and you come home and say
Dad I'm getting bullied and your dad
grabs you by the collar and says when
you walk into school tomorrow you get
off that bus you walk straight into the
lockers and you hit that kid in the
mouth as hard as you can
that is not honoring your dad by hitting
him it's acting like a child like he is
okay yes so
um one is obedience is honor one is
Disobedience designed I'm not gonna go
hit a kid in the mouth that's not gonna
make this better
um or if
the opposite happens if my son witnessed
somebody another kid in his grade
beating up a girl in the hallway
I would fully expect him to intervene so
I've trained him to do right to make
sure people are safe
and so
all I have to say is this how old are
you now
I'm 28. okay
my guess is
mom had a very rigid way of doing life
because that's the only way she could
survive
that's the house she grew up in you also
grew up without a dad you've got a lot
of childhood trauma okay
and the the research on immigrant
parents and first-gen kids and all that
is both like really makes for really
sexy headlines and also those are scary
houses to grow up in
both in right it's cool to tell the
story like man my mom made it
whoo that was 20 years of whoa
and there's a lot of those stories that
don't get told her mom didn't make it
right so we know that you live through
that my guess is now Mama's starting to
tell you continue to tell you how you're
living your life and what you should be
doing
and I'm your mom are you just gonna
disobey your mom
and the answer is honor in this case
the best way you can honor your mom is
to be well in whole
because she raised you to be fiercely
independent
to make hard choices to walk away when
you need to to work like nobody's
business with a work ethic
and that might mean telling her no I'm
not going to do that this time I'm doing
something different
doing everything she says and getting
crucified is not uh honor
yes so give me an example of something
she's telling you to do that you don't
want to do anymore
oh
centered I am the first born in
accordance you know birth order and I'm
also the oldest girl
um so the expectation to always take
care of people is something that I also
struggle with
um but recently I finished my second to
last semester of nursing school so I'm
entering that phase of my life
and she wants me to stay in our town
um which I don't want to do
I've lived here for 28 well close to 28
years 20 more so and
I don't I don't want to be here I feel
that I have callings to go elsewhere I
feel like I need to go I don't have
Community here yeah and I think if I was
you I'd sit down the conversation and
say Mom at a young age
um
you had to go and you had to go for an
abusive reason I've got to go for to go
make my mark
You Raised Me This Way
I'm so grateful you gave me the courage
because a lot of people just stay in
their same small town and they die there
and you're saying time for me to go
and that that departure will be met with
all kinds of I can't believe you're
abandoning your family what about this
that's about them
it's probably because you're such an
amazing daughter
that your mom has come to rely on You
Like Oxygen right and she's a grown-up
and she's gonna have to find connections
there and this doesn't mean you're gone
forever
but it might mean we're I'm gonna go
make a place for us and then I'll come
back and get you like it can mean any
number of things but I think you need to
go
because here's what's gonna happen if
you don't
you're going to start to resent your mom
and I don't think she deserves that I
don't think you deserve that I don't
think your relationship deserves that
I agree and it can be a two-year thing
hey I'm gonna try this out for two years
and that might give your mom a little
dot dot give her an opportunity to grow
into it might give you an opportunity to
grow into it
and it doesn't sound so Eternal or so
forever but I think you need to make a
list of the things your mom is asking
you to do or demanding of you if you
will and walk through
probably with a close friend would be
best but to walk through these and say
okay
as I'm 28 years old I'm graduating
college I'm about to hit the market and
go see the world
um
how much of this stuff is honor and how
much of this is my mom just wants me
around
or how much of this is cultural from the
old world to and I'm making some changes
in my personal life I'm adopting new
parts of new cultures and I'm gonna go
do x y and z
let's just choosing reality right it's
just owning it mm-hmm no I'm telling you
to do that what's the feeling in your
guts like yes or is it oh no
I've tried to do that um
and
uh it was really hard because the
support system that I had gone to to get
counseling on it
um was a pastor of mine and I just they
knew that I was having issues with
identities they knew I was having issues
with
being independent as an adult should or
or even just chart that what that feels
like and I remember sitting down and
telling her I think it's time for me to
go and she said oh it's because of that
new church that you joined oh gosh you
should have gone up and walked out you
should have got up and walked out
oh my gosh like sit down with your
Barber and being like oh I see somebody
else cut your hair like what what are we
doing here yeah you see how that that
Pastor made your
Quest your adventure what comes next for
you your identity
all about her
yeah it's not that's not how you do that
you sit down with somebody it's man I'm
sorry that happened to you
lucky for you you've got some
knuckleheaded uh podcaster that you've
never met I'll be sure to tell you no I
I mean I I think you gotta go I think
you gotta go I think you gotta go see
and I also think you got to be honest
with your mom I think you got to be
honest with you are gonna feel
incredibly guilty
and your mom probably wouldn't be your
mom if she didn't just lay it on super
thick
and if some of her friends and some of
your extended family members can't
believe you're abandoning everybody okay
but I think you need to go again I would
tell you let's go try this for two years
let's go try this for three years
and see what happens
let's see what happens
when we left Texas and my wife and I
left Texas um we left our all of our
family all of our friends our whole
thing and to move to Nashville to work
at at the University
um I said let's give this three years
and let's see what living in another
state and their community and dude it's
been magic it's been awesome
so yeah I think it's time and and again
remember
doing every single solitary thing your
parents says even when you're 30 years
old that's not on that's not
honor
living the life that they trained you to
live to the fullest
taking care of them when they need care
setting up support networks that they
can opt in or out of
I don't want to live there I want to
live here I can't afford there well then
you don't love me well I'm not taking
out a mortgage right
honor is a much bigger conversation than
I said so
go go see the world let me know when you
get there I want to hear how it goes
sounds like an adventure awaits we'll be
right back
hey good folks deloni here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time those become healthy habits
they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
Hollow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling Hollow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hallow.com deloney today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hallow.com deloney for 90
days free
all right let's go out to Detroit Rock
City and talk to the great and wonderful
Ashley what's up Ashley
Hi how are you rocking out to the
Breaking Dawn what are you doing
um
decision I submitted yesterday awesome
hey um do me a favor talk directly into
your phone okay
can you hear me perfect Perfect okay
okay all right so what's up what have
you done now just kidding
so
um I am struggling I'm an emotional
person so this I am really hard I am too
it's all good
I'm struggling to be a single mom
um after a divorce and just finding my
places
alone because I never saw myself being
um alone I'm in a relational person like
I I want to be in a relationship I want
to enjoy adventure and fun with somebody
and it's just I'm really struggling with
being alone what happened in your
marriage
sorry but
but
um he ended it there was a lot of there
was a lot of trauma that happened with
my side of the family and some things
that happened that he wasn't happy with
and that he wouldn't support me through
wanting to support my family and so we
we but it has a lot in that in the end
um but also ultimately I felt like he
was pulling away from me and
um was a very um avoidant
and dismissive person and so when we
tried to go through therapy resolving
that and saying I did more
um really really I was stuck on my love
languages and that I need affection and
words of affirmation and he couldn't
give that to me I felt very alone and so
um I don't know if it was me pressing
that and you know at the end plus some
of the things that went on with um
conflicts with were my extended family
um he filed in the end
did it surprise you
um
and then he was just kind of a more of a
stoic like didn't show his affection but
it just felt like it got worse when
um
I lost my dad's dramatically and I lost
my brother dramatically and I just felt
very much alone in that and then when he
tried to say that he didn't want
anything to do with the rest of my
family because of something that my
brother had done
um I just felt abandoned I think and I
think I'm still struggling with that is
there a chance that
um yeah you should be stroking with that
that's hard
is there a chance that
you left him too
um
I think he just filed their paperwork I
signed yeah
yeah actually and I begged him not to do
it but I know that when it was all said
and done
um Mayo 2022 a huge weight was lifted
off my shoulders
because of how he treated me so I know
that I'm I was not with the person that
I that I would have wanted to be with
forever like I eventually I might have
ended things
um but I wasn't raised that way my
parents were very happily married so I I
there's part of me that feels like I
failed and I failed my kids
um but I do know that I'm happier now
without him in my life I just know it's
causing me
to struggle with where I'm at single and
feeling lonely
um
there's a lot of different routes we
could take
give me a no there's a lot I know it's
okay you're not a lot Kelly Kelly is a
lot you are not
um so give me um like give me a
particular question we can work on
who I am because I'm I know that I
struggle with
um my own identity and being okay with
who I am because I think
I said there's still something there
with feeling like I wasn't enough for
him so I'm not enough for someone else
okay so those are two completely
different things all right the first
thing is if you're not if you're not
happy being single Don't force yourself
to pretend that you're happy that you're
single
yeah it's okay to grieve that I miss
somebody
yeah and you miss
just knowing that somebody's in the
house in case there's a sound you miss
sex you miss sharing a meal with
somebody you miss silliness you probably
even miss the conflict a little bit just
Mis engagement right yeah I wouldn't
pretend that you're not feeling that
that's going to make you insane right
yeah or like to give you a picture
if you take that feeling and you don't
want to feel it
like you press it down you shove it down
or you compress it another word for that
is to depress it
right and your body goes oh we got it
those things aren't good so we don't
want to do that right the second thing
you're talking about confidence
because you're asking yourself the
question what was so bad about me that
he wouldn't just say I love you and give
me a back rub what was so bad about me
right what was so bad about me that when
he was stressed at work I was in his
safe place to come
um
like be with
so bad about me that he wouldn't be with
me when my dad died and my brother died
and that's a question of confidence
and so the hard the hardest turn to make
is
he didn't show up when my dad and my
brother died because something was wrong
with him not me
okay
and confidence is not something you can
just whip up you can't just imagine it
confidence is something you have to
practice
your body knows the difference we failed
miserably with the self-esteem movement
right they studied a whole bunch of CEOs
and they saw that these super successful
people had insane
belief in themselves
and so what they tried to do is go back
and give that to kids just tell kids
they're wonderful stop having trophy
stop letting kids lose or get second
place we all win we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna inject this AB this insane
self-confidence what they failed to
realize and we've got a generation that
grew up thinking that they're the
greatest thing that ever lived is those
CEOs gained that insane self-confidence
by failing a million times
right and getting beat up and beat up
and they kept dragging themselves to one
more step and one more step and one more
step so by the time they finally got to
the top of whatever Hill they were
trying to climb dude they were the most
confident guys in the world because
they've been dragged down so much and
that's different
okay and so you got knocked completely
over
some by your own doing some by him
somebody just the the nature of your
relationship man for whatever reason
couldn't sit down and say let's let's
dig into this yep
so you have to go on a journey to be
weird
as how old are you
42. oh gosh making friends at 42 the
worst I have amazing friends honestly I
do because I've had a couple girlfriends
who've gone through divorce and they're
my rock so I do have I know hold on but
they can be your rock but I've hung out
with a bunch of divorced women before
right
yeah yes right and I've hung out with
divorced dudes before when there's three
or four and it's like bro bro and I just
want to set my face on fire to make sure
I can still feel right
so it is good to have people who have
been there before who are like down the
road from you to get some wisdom from
but you also need people in your life
who still love the idea of love
yeah and who are still actively seeking
connection
and you're gonna have to just be weird
about some of these pictures you have in
your head about this is the way this
works
I just sit idly by in my church pew and
some guy Taps me on the shoulder and
says would you and you're like I would
like that's not gonna happen I know
right it's not gonna happen so you're
gonna have to be weird you might have to
ask somebody at your office place he
didn't go get coffee or somebody at the
daycare center where your kid works or
your kid goes I I don't I don't know
your world or you have to say hey I'm
back on the market ladies I've gotta
I've got to slowly take little baby
steps into this thing and dating is
the absolute miserable worst it's worse
than making friends as I've been told
right it is I've tried yep okay so
remember back to those CEOs
it's you're gonna have to just decide
I'm gonna keep scratching and clawing
one more step one more step one more
step
okay because you're practicing
confidence and let's be super super
honest
um have you sat down and been reflective
on what role you played in your marriage
um yes okay I've been through a lot of
therapy and
um
I know that I was codependent
um I was a stay-at-home mom for the last
six years and I kind of lost myself and
um I know I played a role in that way
that I just felt
um
I was very dependent on him at times for
my happiness instead of finding my
happiness somewhere else outside of just
him
I don't think it's necessarily bad to
find happiness and to begin to lean on
your spouse
I don't think that's codependent
codependent is when I'm gonna bury
myself in order to make sure they're
okay
um and I that okay I was so
that I kind of I just felt like I really
let myself go and
um you know I but I also think that I I
created that in my mind because I didn't
have him telling me out anything else
that's fair that's fair I thought it
wasn't good enough for him because he
wasn't saying those things so I think
I'm not sure I'm not 100 sure exactly
what I did I got so let me say it like
this
um the only way marriage works is if
both people go all in
like in in a way that's insane it
doesn't make any sense right right like
I am all in on you this is it
and you got to be all in on me and when
that doesn't work or it falls apart
often the solution is kind of a
misguided definition of codependency and
that which basically means the next time
I'm gonna go one foot in because I
always have to keep one foot on the
ground one foot in the boat's fine but
one on the ground to make sure that I'm
doing what I need to do so that I can
and I'm here to tell you
that's not gonna work
right
what you have to do is be willing to
risk getting hurt this bad again
yeah and I think I am there because I
I am the kind of person that
um
I wear my heart on my sleeve I tell you
how I tell them how I feel you know I've
dated and I've been in a couple you know
short-lived relationships and I feel
like maybe like I always question did I
give too much did I tell that person too
much did I you know share I share a lot
because I want them to know everything
about me and who I am and what I'm
willing to give so let me tell you this
you probably are a lot and there is
somebody who loves a lot
and so walking away every time that's
just that anxiety spinning up on you I
said this I shouldn't have laughed like
that oh my gosh I ate this and I should
have put my Fork down like that right
what I want you to take full ownership
of is I'm freaking Ashley I've been
there
I'm a good mom I'm raising my daughters
I was married to a cop
which I grew up in that household
actually I know that's a whole different
ecosystem right like there's not a lot
and now I'm looking for somebody to just
um for like
rock on till the wheels fall off I don't
have a good time and so this is I'm not
playing games anymore and a lot of the
modern dating is set up literally like a
video game it's a game yeah right it's a
swipe right let's meet I'm gonna give
you a thumbs down emoji or no dude I'm
just gonna tell you I'm hard on my sleep
kind of person
and my promise is that those people are
out there who love honesty and
directness and somebody that's a little
bit whoa that's a lot
right
but if you start hedging yourself
you're gonna end up in the same spot
again
it's both feet I think I I think I did
that in the beginning when I first met
my husband
I wasn't a lot I didn't wear my heart on
my sleeve and then when I started to
truly become who I was in the marriage I
don't think he liked it
and that's really hard right
my husband liked a pseudo version of me
but I want to back up and say it again
that was an issue with him
right
did you give it your all
I did you gotta let that go
like you're still trying to fix it now
yeah
can't fix it it's over what you can't do
is build something else that's rad yeah
there
yep
do you want rad what does rad feel like
um
laughter I'm not very I love to laugh I
love to be funny I love to
be on adventures in a very athletic so I
just love to be out trying new things
I'm spontaneous
that's what I want I promise you there's
guys listening to this looking at their
wives now going oh geez how do I get in
contact with Ashley
okay
what you just laid out is a dream it's
awesome
okay
and if you had laid out I just I'm kind
of boring and I'm a nerd I like to read
books and go to bed at nine o'clock and
I don't I like just being stable there's
some guy listening going yeah yes right
right
it's when you feel yourself
um gosh I'm trying to think uh
something extraordinary and it's on the
internet somewhere that brene brown
talked about but about
belonging
is devastating
it when a person or as a person begins
to look around and say okay what do
these people need from me so that I can
be included
right and that's dangerous maybe the
words not belonging but that's the
sentiment when you start
hiding parts of yourself so that maybe
they'll ask me out again that thing's
already that thing's already sunk man
right
somebody's gonna love the dance you do
when the tacos are delicious
okay
they are they just don't yep Fair yep
all right hang on the line I'm gonna
send you a copy of uh building an
unanxious life and I want you to read
all the way through it and do all the
exercises in the back you're here's what
you are you are rebuilding
you're rebuilding something you're
rebuilding how you think of yourself
you're rebuilding your day-to-day you're
rebuilding what a home looks like you're
grieving what you thought this thing was
going to look like and now it's
different you're rebuilding everything
and as any building project goes you
always are like all right I'm gonna get
the foundation down on Monday no you're
not it's gonna take like seven days or
14 days or 22 days because it rained one
day it's just gonna take a while that's
okay it's all right
it's never forgetting I'm not there may
be parts of me I gotta change cool
but my Core Essence the core person who
I am dude I'm not I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna put a lid on that just to try to
get temporary approval because that
always always ends at chaos and Ash
and you my friend are worth more than
that it's awesome thank you for calling
you're you're you're a brave woman
Ashley we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-interest life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney.com
[Music]
all right as we wrap up today's show
literally my uh
my friends loved poison and I've come
around they're they're definitely one of
my one of my greats
but my band
was Tesla
not the car the rock band and if you
don't know Tesla what are you doing with
your life
but they came out with a great record
called the five-man acoustical Jam that
changed my life and in so many ways I
should probably do a whole show on that
record one day
and on that song on that record I was
introduced to a song called love song
and it was on another record but man
goes like this
so you think that it's over that your
love has finally reached the end anytime
you call night or day I'll be right
there for you if you need a friend
it's gonna take a little time time is
sure to mend your broken heart but don't
you even worry pretty darling because I
know you'll find love again
love is all around you it's knocking
outside your door waiting for you as a
love made just for two keep an open
heart you'll find love again I know what
a great tune love you guys stay in
school bye
foreign